i am here to provide a service and if i
can open a door for someone
where they understand that it's not as
hard as people make it sound
you know that's the trick of it
mark what do you think makes you
different than the thousands of other
screenwriters
who came to la during your time here
what do you think made it different for
you
well i think i was very very lucky in
the fact that
i was enthusiastic about science fiction
from when i was a small boy
and science fiction unlike a lot of
other genres
the fans became the writers and so they
had a sense of
wanting to pay it forward so when i
noticed that the same writers were
writing for star trek and outer limits
and twilight zone
as we're writing the short stories and
books that i was reading and the novels
ray bradbury harlan ellis and theodore
sturgeon
richard matheson etc i
could then go to science fiction
conventions when i was a teenager
and i sought these wonderful people out
and they became mentors and friends
that that helped enormously and uh
and also i just had such a passion for
writing i had such a
i i had a sense of calling from a very
early age
and i understood that uh
because of rod sterling because of so
many of these writers that i admired
that you could aim high you didn't have
to blend in
you just had to be clear uh
what you were sharing with the world and
ray bradbury was a mentor of mine for
over 10 years i'd go over to his house
once a month for over 10 years
toward the end of his life and ray
always used to say look inward
don't look out for your mature look
inward and that doesn't mean
that you can't write about things that
are different from your life it just
means that you find your passions
and the your true self inward and then
you put that out to the world
and uh and so i i had extremely good
teachers
in that way because i think some writers
out of fear feel that they have to
imitate others or write down to their
audience
i've never felt that i'm the same as my
audience and if i
come across an idea or a story or
characters or whatever that
excites me um usually my audience will
be excited too
by what i'm doing and uh i trust my
audience i don't
i they're they're i feel i'm with my
family
when uh when i'm talking to all the
weirdos
weirdos are good things yeah i like
weirdos yeah yeah yeah
how did you know that you could actually
get something made i mean
there's a lot of people who love a
certain genre but they dabble in it or
they're on the sort of the outside the
outer limits so to speak
how did you know though that you could
get something made and
eventually be successful at it well i
didn't i didn't have a
in terms of knowing that i would be
successful i didn't know that it was
uh there are basically two people who
are responsible for my career more than
anyone
which is my wife elaine who i met when i
was 20. we got married when i was 21 now
we've been together 45 years and married
and we write and produce and direct
together and my friend michael reeves
who was writing for television
and brought me into animation when i was
uh like 22 23 years old
so uh i started by knowing
by the time i got out of art school
about my degrees in painting sculpture
and graphic arts from ucla
and because i always knew i was going to
be an artist or a writer but by the time
i
went through college and then went to
the clarion writers workshop
and sold my first short story i knew i
was going to be a writer and
so i thought well how do you learn how
to be a writer in television
and there was really no there was no
graduate school in that at the time
we're talking the late 70s
and so i thought well i'll write a book
about one of the greatest television
shows ever made
to learn how to make great television
and
so that's why what gave me the idea to
to do the twilight zone companion
it was two years after rod serling's
death and had rod not died prematurely
terribly sadly at age 50. i wouldn't
have embarked upon that book because if
anyone should have written a book about
the twilight zone it would have been rod
but since he wasn't with us anymore i
thought well
let me follow this and see where it
leads now elaine
was invaluable because i started writing
the book interviewing over 100 people
who
had worked on the show and it started
getting rejected when i started
submitting it it was rejected by 25
publishers over a two-year period
and probably if i would if i'd been left
to my own devices
i would have probably quit and elaine
said no no just keep going and
but we also looked at what wasn't
working which was the agent i had
wasn't the right agent she wasn't uh she
wasn't seeing opportunity
to close the deal and so we i switched
agents to someone who was young and
hungry
and she sold it almost immediately to
one of the publishers who already
rejected it
but a different editor who had grown up
with the twilight zone and understood
why people would want to read about that
and and the other thing i think that was
responsible for my success was
sometimes people are so dogged about
this is all i'll do like i mean you know
elaine and i have mentored a lot of
people and one person they said well
i'm i want to act in a stephen spielberg
movie and we said well you know there's
a lot of other things being cast you
could
you could try for other things no no
steven's it's got to be steven spielberg
and so
and we said you know well he might only
do one movie every few years
and and it might not have a role that's
right for you you're limiting your
possibilities
so i knew i wanted to be in television
and i knew
that i wanted to be writing for shows
like star trek but when my friend
michael reeves
was writing animation and he said would
you like to come in and collaborate with
me
i saw that as that got me into
television and then i could
write spec live action features and so
forth and that moved me then into
live-action tv shows but that's how i
ended up writing for smurfs
and he-man and super friends and and all
those shows and uh
but i always brought my a-game to
everything i did so i wasn't writing
down at all
someone once asked me when i was writing
for um animation they said do you write
for the child in the audience and i said
no i write for the child and myself
and so i would go to that place that
would be delighted by the jokes or by
the stories
and then just write as truthfully as i
possibly could and
and that worked and uh so i've i'm very
proud of the work i did in animation
as well as the work i've done in live
action i am here to provide a service
and if i can open a door for someone
where they understand
that it's not as hard as people make it
sound
you know that's the trick of it you know
it's like that's why i wrote green
lighting yourself so people would
know that they could be the engine
that drives their career they don't have
to give up power they don't have to
wait for the studios and the networks or
the publishing companies even
to see their value because thanks to the
internet thanks the fact we all have
cameras
in our pockets thanks the fact we can
edit on um
on a mac or a pc there's no reason not
to just
make the thing you want to make give it
all of your heart and soul
and put it out to the world that's your
audience and that's how you build
a body of work you don't have to wait
there's no reason to
can you succeed in hollywood if you're
not a workaholic
yes you can succeed in hollywood if
you're not a workaholic
but you do have to have a work ethic and
it's interesting in green lighting
yourself in the new book
i talk about having a life and i
deliberately put it
after the chapter on building from
success
and recovering from failure and i
pointed i pointed out in the book
that whether you're succeeding or
whether you're failing it's important to
have a life separate from that
because the separate having people who
love you family
friends travel doing things separate
from the work
it gives you a breadth of experience but
it also
gives you a life it gives you something
that grounds you because you're not just
someone running after the brass ring
and so actually i know
writers who have a very balanced life
between family
and the work and i think that's that's a
good idea i don't think one should work
all the time
because you run out of uh things to draw
upon creatively but you also run out of
i mean you just go crazy the isolation
hollywood can drive people crazy simply
because they get so materialistic
they get so success-oriented driven
that they forget why they got involved
in the first place
you know i've known people who've wanted
to become who want to become writers
because they want to get rich
and i've never seen it work maybe
someone has succeeded that
but the people that i've seen succeed
are the ones who just love
the work and they love what they're
creating and they are just
so grateful for the opportunity and
you know it's just there's something
like for instance i just came from a
studio that i have that's filled with
uh spaceship sets and uh
and you know we we're building an alien
spaceship we're building this
uh hospital in a state a space station
and to be just and we're building
eight-foot-tall creatures and just to be
in that
world and be able to share that world
with
with everyone is um is great but elaine
and i try and stop working
in the early evening we work at least
five days a week and sometimes we'll
work weekends but we try not to
but we um we'll work and then the
evening for an hour or two we'll just
relax and watch a movie or a tv show or
something
or go for a walk or you know we and we
have own dogs and dogs force you to like
get off the sofa stop typing you know go
take them for a walk and and that helps
let the air in
a bit uh you can't i don't think you can
be successful
if you don't have a work ethic and also
i think you have to stand by your word
the more you stand by your your word the
more you have a work ethic the more you
have
um at least craft if not i don't use the
word talent much because i've seen a lot
of people who had talent who got nowhere
whereas if you have passion and craft
and a work ethic and and you
um i mean you know the reason people
support me in so many ways is because if
i say i'm going to do something i do it
and it doesn't matter if it's easier if
it's hard if it's hard then it's hard
it's i'm not going to stop i'm not going
to
turn back i have i have work to do you
know i get on with it
and my mantra to myself when things are
difficult is
you know i'm made of iron and nothing
will stop me and there are times for
instance when i did the star trek
episode with george takei
it was a very grueling shoot and uh and
i
said i'm made of iron and nothing will
stop me and i had to use that
but we got to the finish line and that
got nominated for the hugo and the
nebula and i'm
very very proud of that episode still
and that was for christina moses's
first tv role we cast her out of the
blue and
she's now starring on a million little
things on abc so we saw what her
amazing talent was right from the
beginning
well you talked about talent and talent
is very long
in this in this town but but what if
someone's sort of the pendulum swings
more toward a hedonistic
personality type well i try not to hang
out with
they're gonna be a really nice hedonist
yeah they know but i mean i think
you have to treat your body
like a car that you might own and you
want to take care of it you want to make
sure that you aren't
burning the candle at both ends you know
so many people burn out
and you know drugs alcohol you know
self-destructive behaviors gambling all
that i it's just
not sustainable in the long run because
it's just too hard on on your mind and
your body
you know it's uh you know i i
i gravitate toward people who have a
family life most of the people i work
with are married
they have many of them have kids um i
want someone who's stable
i don't want someone where i don't know
if they're going to show up and
so i i can make the choice of who i work
with
and i've been very lucky in terms of the
actors i've worked with even when i was
at the studios
and the networks i never had a crazy
person
i always had people who were there to do
the job and they appreciated the fact
that i was
really putting putting everything i
could on the page
and they would get these scripts they
would love what i was writing because it
gave them something
to act some emotional through line and
uh
and you know so quality work gets you
quality actors get you quality composers
and get
there's a ripple effect if you're if
you're doing your your best work but you
can't
be thinking about oh i've got this party
to go to i've got this no
it's um i mean that doesn't mean you
can't have fun
you can't go on vacation you can't go
water skiing or whatever
you know and uh but but at the end of
the day you have to be reliable
and that means you have to like look
ahead you cannot be such an impulse
monster that you know it's monday and
you don't know where you're supposed to
be you know so
can't wander the streets but you know so
uh
so that's yeah but of course in you know
in the new book i talk about if you
if you have thrown together with someone
like that here's how you can
deal with it because i had a friend who
was an actress and she was cast on tv
show huge hit show
and the um the the star of the show was
drinking all day and being very very
abusive to people and very insulting and
she just
but she recognized to not engage to do
her work she was there to do her work
and she did it and ironically at the end
of the day the actor came up and said
you were great
and so she had succeeded i think often
what we have to do is
have our eye on the ball in terms of
what we are there to accomplish
it's not about winning every single
battle it's not about
going toe-to-toe with everyone it's not
an alpha dog contest
it's about what am i trying to
accomplish and so if you say okay well
i'm here to write a great script and
turn it into a great tv show or
i'm here to give a great performance
whatever it is you have to be clear on
it
but obviously the more that you take
power the less you're going to be
frustrated by other people who
are not there for the same purpose so
that's why i have my own studio now
that's why i raise money the way i do
because
um you know it's fun to be in charge
because then
then there's no one around to i mean if
anyone's gonna wreck it it'll be me but
then that's my fault
you know it's like a failing of whatever
but
um but it's so it's so cool to work with
great people and create
work that that has meaning you know i
just i i couldn't be happier
you